e
[Rires]
[Musique]
la ds qui à 20 ans vient donc de mettre
au monde une cx de mines
elle ne ressemble pas tellement à sa
mère mais plutôt à ses cousins c'est une
grosse gs ou peut-être une petite et
sème à quatre portes
[Musique]
conçue il ya quatre ans lorsque la crise
de l'énergie n'était pas encore le
cauchemar des constructeurs elle risque
de paraître aujourd'hui un peu trop
impactées et légèrement gourmande pas
loin de 10 litres aux 100 km à 140 à
l'heure
[Musique]
c'est bien sûr une traction avant à la
suspension hydropneumatique les freins à
disques sont assistés et commandé par
double circuit on trouve aussi sur la cx
un châssis pour supporter les éléments
mécaniques
c'est lui qui encaisse tous les efforts
elle n'est pas faite bien entendu pour
les carambolages
mais en cas de choc contre un mur 60
kilomètres à l'heure par exemple le
recul du volant n'est que de 3 cm alors
que la tolérance actuel est de 13 cm
autre qualité de la cx 2000 une
excellente tenue de route un freinage
puissant une direction très précise et
un confort de conduite remarquable en
longueur et la 24 cm de moins que la ds
8 cm de moins largeur elle est moins
haute de 11 cm les vibrations mécaniques
sont bien filtrer la planche de bord est
originale et très lisse ou la cx 2000
qui pourrait grimper sous s'était permis
à 174 km heure monte à 100 entrées
secondes
elle sera commercialisée dès le mois de
septembre et coûtera 24 1953 sa grande
soeur la cx 2002 arrive à 179 km heure
elle devrait coûter à peine plus cher
pour être commercialisé en janvier
[Musique]